[Música]
estoy seguro que habéis visto esta
imagen miles de veces lo que os pido es
que hoy la veamos con los ojos nuevos
para intentar descubrir mayores matices
yo la utilizo mucho en talleres con
profesorado y les pregunto para qué
utilizaría esta imagen en una clase
y los primeros los más racionales que
son los que responden al principio dicen
pues para hablar del consumo energético
de el mundo o para hablar de la densidad
poblacional
o también hay quien dice pues con esto
podríamos hablar de la historia colonial
o del efecto del clima y de la orografía
en los sentimientos humanos cuando
llevamos entrando en calor llegamos a la
gente que tiene un poco más de capacidad
de profundizar dice esta es la imagen
perfecta para hablar de la desigualdad
en el mundo
o por ejemplo para expresar la paradoja
del origen
el consumo de los recursos naturales
o para hablar de la creciente en proceso
de urbanización en el que estamos
metidos en el mundo
o esta que me gusta mucho quien dice nos
serviría muy bien para hablar de la
relación entre desarrollo y movilidad
humana me encanta esta imagen porque nos
permite ver claramente las diferentes
lecturas que podemos hacer de una misma
mirada las distintas profundidades que
podemos hacer de la misma realidad
y fijaros que siempre en todos los
talleres que hago al final casi como con
timidez y despacito alguien se atreve a
decir yo la utilizaría para preguntar
qué es lo que sabemos de aquellos sitios
donde no hay luz
los reto a pensar mentalmente cuál es
este país y cuál es su capital o por
ejemplo este otro que régimen político
tiene algún pensador famoso que haya
tenido influencia
o este otro cual es el recurso principal
que tiene su economía o por ejemplo cuál
ha sido el último conflicto que han
vivido
estaréis conmigo qué
hay muchísimas realidades de las que
apenas sabemos nada
y es normal pero es importante hacerse
esta pregunta
de qué sé
sobre que leo de qué hablo cuando tengo
cafés con mis amigos y mis amigas de que
puedo decir que estoy más o menos al
tanto qué es lo que me mueve a mí cuando
busco información esto es importantísimo
para aquellos que por ejemplo tenéis
familia o trabajamos en los medios de
comunicación o en educación
filosóficamente la pregunta sería cómo
me relaciono con la realidad que va más
allá de mi contexto
y esto es importantísimo porque la
pregunta en el fondo es qué mundo
transmitimos a las generaciones más
jóvenes de qué hablamos o más bien de
qué no hablamos y por lo tanto quizá
estemos perpetuando estas zonas de
sombra que a nadie le importan de las
que nadie sabe lugares a los que nadie
mira
y esto es bien normal ocurre mucho en la
historia de la humanidad es bien difícil
ser consciente o interpretar situaciones
y eventos históricos cuando no los está
viviendo
hace bien poco veíamos en las noticias
que no se escandalizaba que la mediados
del siglo 19 aquí en españa teníamos
anuncios en prensa a los que se vendían
esclavos
nos parece alucinante
o por ejemplo hace unos años me fui en
coche desde mi casa hasta auschwitz solo
para unir mi realidad con uno de los
episodios más oscuros de la historia de
la humanidad
que empecé a que lo estudiamos en los
libros de historia ha ocurrido como
quien dice ayer a unas 20 horas en coche
desde aquí desde victoria
no es flipante
o algo mucho más cercano el muro de
berlín todavía recuerdo en el 89 cuando
cayó el muro estar viendo las noticias
me parece cuando menos sorprendente el
pensar cómo la población coetánea de ese
momento pudieron convivir con la
existencia de estos 160 kilómetros de
muro y de vallas que durante 26 años
dividieron a la población impidiendo su
libre circulación más de 100 mil
personas intentaron saltar esta valla
muchas de ellas fueron detenidas algunos
perecieron esto ha ocurrido muchísimo en
la historia de la humanidad poblaciones
enteras han vivido durante mucho tiempo
ignorando realidades bien visibles que
luego con la luz del tiempo y de la
historia hemos calificado de injusticias
sangrantes
qué difícil es interpretar la realidad
cuando somos parte de ella
no sé si conocéis esta ciudad es una
ciudad española
una bonita foto bonita ciudad es ceuta
está en el lado africano del estrecho de
gibraltar
son 18 kilómetros cuadrados del
territorio separados de marruecos por
una valla de 8 km de largo y 6 metros de
altura y os tengo que confesar que la
mitad de las fotos que he puesto cuando
hablaba del muro de berlín eran de
nuestra valla de ceuta una valla que
está funcionando en este momento que
está sostenida con nuestros impuestos
que está defendida por nuestras fuerzas
de seguridad es nuestro país
en esta valla se da el salto del pib más
grande del mundo es la frontera en la
que se da el salto más grande del mundo
fue construido en el año 98 con fondos
paradójicamente llamados de la unión
europea para el desarrollo regional
las cuenta de la paradoja para crear el
espacio schengen y tener una europa sin
fronteras nos vemos obligados a crear la
frontera más desigual del mundo en la
que en este momento estamos frenando
las expectativas las ilusiones los
caminos de miles de personas que están
escapando de la pobreza de la injusticia
de la persecución de la guerra
estoy convencido que en el futuro
alguien en una charla como ésta mirará
hacia atrás y dirá cómo pudieron vivir
tranquilos y tranquilas con semejante
vulneración de derechos en su patio
trasero
esto es por lo que me gusta llevar a la
gente joven a ceuta porque cuando
descubren la valla
uno puede apreciar en sus ojos cómo
cambian para siempre la percepción de
nuestro mundo es como al darse cuenta de
que nuestro concepto de estado del
bienestar está apoyado en semejante
barrera de contención cambia para
siempre la forma a la que entendemos el
mundo es lo mismo
en el show de truman no sé si visteis la
película cuando el protagonista escapa
en el velero y choca contra el decorado
y todo lo que hasta ese momento había
sido el mundo para él se da cuenta de
que se trata de un escenario de un plató
de televisión
conocer la valla de ceuta y de melilla
para la gente joven equivale a este
despertar a la complejidad del mundo es
añadir un nivel más de profundidad a la
interpretación de ese mapa mundi es
iluminar una zona que estaba a oscuras
y una vez que se descubre ya no hay
marcha atrás esto es lo que llamamos
conciencia de ciudadanía global por la
que todos y todas deberíamos de pasar
y esto está yendo a más si en el año 89
cuando cayó el muro de berlín había 16
muros y bayas en fronteras exteriores
del mundo el año pasado contabilizábamos
ya 70 solo en la unión europea hemos
construido en los últimos 30 años casi
1000 kilómetros de vallas y muros
exteriores de ellos
2 bayas en nuestro país 18 puntos 7
kilómetros y pese a que los expertos
dicen una y otra vez que esta no es
manera de gestionar los flujos
migratorios en los últimos cinco años se
han construido 25 nuevos muros y bayas
en el mundo más que en ningún otro
período de la edad moderna
y lo curioso es que estas bayas o estos
muros son simbólicos más que reales
porque no son eficientes está comprobado
que no disuaden y mucho menos resuelven
el problema de la movilidad forzosa o de
la movilidad humana lo que ocurre es que
mueven los flujos a otros lugares
normalmente a rutas más inseguras con
mayor peligro
en el año 2016 se batió el récord de
muertes de personas cruzando una
frontera en el mundo 7200
de ellas 5000 en nuestro querido
mediterráneo
vaya si nos toca de cerca este problema
en este momento una de cada trece
personas que intentan cruzar de libia
hasta italia fallecen
pensemos bien quien en su cordura es
capaz de jugarse la vida con semejante
probabilidad
salvo que esté a la desesperada
son personas
igual que nosotros nos escandaliza
hablar de la esclavitud de los campos de
concentración nos van a mirar y van a
decir pero no se dieron cuenta de que
eran seres humanos
la única manera en la que estamos
conviviendo con esta situación fijaros
bien es
porque los tenemos a oscuras
porque no tiene el rostro no tiene el
nombre no tienen historia no hay
relación no nos importan
por eso es tan importante poner luz ser
conscientes
experimentar crear relación
porque si fuera en nuestra familia con
nuestros conocidos os aseguro que
encontraríamos la manera de solucionar
esta situación
así que dejarme que lo diga bien claro
el concepto actual de frontera que
manejamos es inhumano y en el futuro se
escandalizarán de la forma en la que
estamos abordando la movilidad humana en
un mundo donde cada vez hay más vallas
cada vez hay más muros cada vez hay más
fronteras contra personas
y la clave está en nuestra conciencia de
ser parte de la familia humana quién es
mi gente y por qué ellos no
o la conciencia de ciudadanía global
hasta dónde llega aquello de lo que yo
me siento responsable y por qué de esto
no
así que ojalá la próxima vez que vayamos
a buscar que el libro leer o sobre que
leer en internet o de qué vamos a hablar
en el próximo café con nuestros amigos y
amigas recordemos la enorme fuerza que
podemos tener solo trayendo luz sobre la
movilidad humana que es una de las
grandes causas sociales de nuestra era
sin duda uno de los mayores errores
colectivos de nuestro tiempo
y no olvidéis
la enorme fuerza que tiene la toma de
consciencia colectiva de forma
progresiva porque a lo largo de la
humanidad se ha demostrado ser
la más importante fuerza para el cambio
capaz de tumbar y derribar muros y
barreras que en su tiempo parecían
imposibles
así que pongamos luz con esta situación
depende de ti depende de mí depende de
todos
abramos los ojos
es nuestro tiempo
que no nos digan que no nos dimos cuenta
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]